Do you know that June 9 all Europeans
we are called to GO to the polls?
European elections held
and if you get caught out of the house,
you can request a vote by mail now.
You have until May 30 to apply
through the mailing website or at any office
postal with your ID card.
The ballots of the different
matches to be presented
will arrive home on May 20 and you will be able to
cast your vote in any office
until June 5th.
If you still have doubts
on how to vote by mail in these elections
European elections,
do not hesitate to contact us.
We help you
with all procedures free of charge.
call 6 17 57 80 84
or approach 65 Segismundo More Street
Tuesday afternoon,
we are waiting for you!